so Rishi to the Bell morning the morning
it's actual morning for me like in real
life
IRL gamer feels so good Ring Ding Ding
adenine my C is actually sleeping and I
feel like I'm waking her up and I feel
like I'm making all the neighbors angry
well let's start here no so I did a fish
farm but it doesn't work help me
Internet I'm asking oh yeah we did the
paper form right and we actually have
sex so we should now we can finally make
I'm liking all the energy because it's
me now we can finally make steak yeah
they're not going anywhere
I do have five bookshelves so wait so we
don't even need them last time do you
have in love with Epis listen I think
we're still a chest yeah we fifty give
me strong okay put a month put them up
remote I'm up break it up no no I'm
dummy dum-dum I'm Jack okay I said stop
you have to stop where you can making
you wait how do you make a bookshelf
yeah
leather and paper to make a book here
take these I don't care anymore I'm done
here look oh ah thank you
I've got to the same masu he speaking
the language of the nihon yesterday I
was gonna buy a SIM card and I think I
said instead of it's called it's a very
Americanized word like sim Jim Joe
but I said Tim Tim called for critici--
and they're like what what is he saying
I'm like come on seriously yeah he's a
sim card well I missed Oh No okay
yeah we're its bleep okay um
Pigman why don't you help us he's he's a
freaking black bloc whoa dude
controversial time can sing it because
I'm Swedish yeah how did that work out
before stop what are we doing I am
building a sward now we're in chanting
Wow
wait how many times do you know we have
five I feel like we should make an
enchant no nevermind
we keep them secret keep it secret keep
it safe but now now we can you send some
I also like how you were building all of
this stuff and tricking me and killing
me in everything but you got rid of our
potato nevermind we had a potato friend
yes
potato firm and I grew it myself I was
very proud fine oh oh we did have a
potato farm I'm sorry bro
that's on me and I'm willing to
apologize right now
how'd you sleep oh there's phantoms in
sleep river the river of shame are you
sleeping
wait you mean they're monsters nearby oh
come on you're on the bed you're fine
wait hold on my ceiling the same
[Laughter]
I'll join you an epic sleep soon gamer
no you you made the sleep you were there
I understand sleep oh no I guess you
don't wake up you understood you you big
brain move it's time for me to show the
other epic contraption Wow are you
really should be more hyped yeah I can't
do that oh god yeah sometimes I recorded
in the morning people like what is wrong
with a Minecraft all-night drug do you
know what this is this is an important
point
what's it observing what triggers it why
well your PB so small no trigger or
anything
hey stop I need to me I need to make
brain okay I have no food and I've now
have no healthy means soft potatoes okay
but when you're done come back here okay
I don't need a furnace for God my brain
doesn't work either well I never said my
brain didn't worry no I did about you
I'm yelling wait does that work works if
you do it for real okay okay so go and
go to the front and then stand still
right now okay are you ready
I I can do that yes are you ready yes
Wow we are going we are going on a
stinky smooth brain so Jack I built this
pit and I'm gonna put you in as a joke
but I'm like now that's mean I'm kind of
over oh my god I just fell anyway
[Laughter]
oh my god I could see you see me oh
there you are
Wow did you learn that from mumbo-jumbo
I think this is like a common one but
maybe he's probably done it faster oh
yeah he did that you're right Wow
the great penis place hey hey wait you
know it's none of them epic wow this is
as loud as a real blanket
ow wow you took fall damage from water
or that's so weird because you fell in
the hole yeah it's gonna go forever
we'll see it in a couple days
oh my god it's pretty badass from
underneath yeah this is awesome this is
gonna prove that minecraft goes off
forever because it's not going to come
around the other side oh maybe
well my craft world goes on forever this
is not by me you you basically you
basically launched a satellite to go
explore you can make missiles as well
Phil it explodes on anything
you knew this at work we've been trying
to figure out how to make sugar cane
firm oh god I'm so small brain you're
doing all these epic contraptions and
I'm over here being like I keep trying
to do things on my own in Minecraft and
I realized that that's probably not the
way to do it because minecraft doesn't
teach you anything what do you mean
looking up any tutorials like yeah I
mean how to make this and that there's
the cat in the village what we have to
capture yeah okay okay I'll get some you
fish yeah I'm getting fish at this river
over warming's real guys I knew it just
paralyzed I have no gear anymore cats
here oh I see it I see it you got to do
the call
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's in the water paralyzed it stop stop
stop don't kill her you have to make you
thank Sam oh you're not going anywhere
yeah you go fun fish I caught him anyway
this is keeping the water okay I have to
fish the cows is gonna be enough this is
gonna work there you go where are you
did you kill the fish No and now it
drowned no cat never drowned cat land on
feet your name will be making it good to
have you as part of the family you
should make him say we should eternal
ice mama in the glass
yes exactly Skelly a skillet on an
inside man okay well I'm going back to
the base because whoa please mama okay
are you okay yeah it's mom okay call him
by his proper name are you think oh I
didn't know you were talking about
before mmm
understand I don't know cuz the cat's
not following in a deck he'll be
crouching what what are you gonna do to
me
just look down here you seen the diamond
good how did you I didn't see any
diamonds of the way down I started
getting towards the bottom and I was
like wait where's my man I don't know we
think they're sitting somewhere we get a
bring back my man you do that I'm gonna
go eat back and talk to mama okay
your pronunciations a little off but
I'll get I'll get it one day yeah all
right I can't join my wooden tower get a
leash you're a big Minecraft youtuber
you'll figure it out man I can breathe
in water yeah doesn't mess around
oh okay now my my stand mama to the
stands
Oh teleported nice it's moment by you
yep
why exactly come come
I would never push money don't worry oh
my god don't know how stop is not the
way damn it you're signing if you die in
Minecraft no I have no items I can run
with signs and bread just like real life
okay make mama said I'm tired okay
sleep sleep mama come in no don't you
dare sleep in my hair you sleep with me
stop be jumpy the job he's getting let's
kill them
no no get out of house why not allowed
anymore
oh no oh sorry
kill mama I didn't mean I swear I swore
oh god I swore you smart I'm going to
swap it now okay oh wait there's so much
time in than potatoes here hey hey okay
since I I killed accident me
I'm glad you use the right terminology
you get too sore pit money I think
that's how it works
I deserve this now I'm going to make
epic thing I'm gonna make epic diamond
sword and then I'm going to know he's
crazy
what is wrong with you what is wrong
with you oh I killed Felix so I guess I
put time and then swore pit swore pit no
I don't deserve this I still have a
sword swore I swore baby so many epics
wars Oh
he rang them the bell of sorriness I
declare bankruptcy so close oh so sad
boomer don't you ever ever call me
boomer I am German oh now I have epic
air oh I shake at you I deflect your
arrow back oh matrix dodge that was
pretty cool I'm sorry I'm so sorry I
used magic Jitsu to knock you down
understandable Adrian
okay Jane should we head out somewhere
sure since you have somewhere to garmr
yeah those are mine so hey guys welcome
back to Minecraft today we're going to
build an iron firm or unlimited iron
what you're going to need is six
villagers one zombie and we should build
I want to I don't know just how do you
get the villagers up to the thing you do
minecart you took be jumpy to be okay my
first name is obese Snoopy I'm sorry
I have to send him down this war pit now
don't do bad our horses kiss I know we
have to plan our Minecraft wedding I
said that I would marry you if I ever
played Minecraft Oh swing minecraft
together oh I know where we can get Matt
makes a mistake it's kind of a sick beat
what the bush bush should attack you
this way lead the way oh boy are you use
it losing your Swedish accent now since
you went to the D home the nihon know it
it's magnifying money what do you mind
go
right next to you no it isn't it's going
yeah yeah I don't see it anymore can I
get on your horse oh yeah oh my god what
is happening
oh my floaty oh my god yes steal him I
want to see you right within oh the gold
makes them faster no wait you're you're
sitting in the water for me oh I'm all
the way up on the top of this okay we'll
leave him and enter again over here gave
her okay and then treated again so I
just stay in the yeah yeah yeah you're
vibrating like a vibrator you're a
vibrator bro okay this is perfect for
our wedding because initially I wanted
an alpha count in our wedding we Marcia
the fake wedding oh yeah yeah it was
just a wedding for the public for the
public it wasn't real in Japan they you
can have a alpha cancer as your wedding
person thing they get a little bowtie
and you should add penguins I was
promised penguins yeah I know
well PR burn allow it apparently in the
water or something like I don't
understand what the issue is all they
need is fish in a happy dance I mean you
said it I wasn't gonna say it but you
said it he's spitting back no oh my god
this is like the scene at the end of
neverending story oh no oh yes oh my god
I'm shocked when I saw that for the
second time he gets over his horse dying
a horrible death pretty something I
gotta say Bakker is way better although
he's terrifying me as a kid yes we're
going 500 blocks this way trees yeah cuz
we're so epic your horse might have
broken ankles by the time he gets here
that's fine yours too okay it's balanced
yeah
Dinah's will be like an epic gamer oh we
should make Santos and minecraft the
giant gauntlet I think there's a mod for
that and wonder if that works in
multiplayer
if both hats the pack okay okay
are you ready Jack do a gamer become God
but that doesn't work yeah okay and now
and now for the moment say bye-bye to
your favorite cow jack oh no I'm like a
living vine compilation' oh did you just
turn it to nighttime power that you have
why can't they fantasy jack I don't know
I can sign us you watch hey stop should
make two of them I'll put them in both
hands
yeah wait Jake look creeper oh man more
like bye-bye man it doesn't work wait I
got it I got it whoa now the glove is
mine
no no I went back home give me the gun
hey I'll show you one thing what did
this it's the worst thing I've ever seen
this is so disappointing we could share
the gauntlet follow me does it only do
one specific purpose yeah here it is
[Laughter]
we literally have a stop gondola now
stop oh my god he's kind of sexy we
should bring him back
oh god I'm about to be attacked Oh God
stop stop no Faunus and something wrong
considers and balancing earth you okay
who wants to get a thing oh my god
there's so many people ready for Thanos
over here you ready you ready to witness
my power
hey you're fighting you should stop wait
doesn't work you gotta aim at their head
oh I see stop killing each other
everyone meet Thanos this is Stannis
goal all along he's true purpose wait no
don't do it on me my gauntlet I'm
running away I'm taking my ball and
going home
wait can I do it to a spider yeah that's
a good cry sing creeper working yeah
that's why you can just stand those
creepers what I'm gonna do it whoa it's
a powerful seven for just turning people
into Thanos
oh my god they went into the trap this
is how we'll beat the ender dragon yeah
I'm sorry
that's okay at least we turned everyone
into Thanos but there's other things we
can do follow me oh my god
ten out of ten oh this does put a smile
on my face
[Laughter]
no oh
cuz there's Thanos yes I'm doing it it's
working
get him
[Laughter]
okay let's tennis volleyball oh nice my
games too delayed oh there's another gas
behind Oh with the banners didn't ya
reality can be whatever I wanted to see
it's also disappoint my games too laggy
I can't time it you can't come on
reality's often disappointing where's
another thing here what were you doing
me yeah oh I was trying to build a cuz
we need to enter our eye of Enders right
I was gonna make a portal to the desert
see don't go through it I wonder if we
find it don't go through it yeah you
can't tell me what to do I'm financed by
gamers okay go to an epic place enjoy
this is exactly those like I told you
the complete opposite of deserts all
walk yes they work so you get one of
these which is a lucky block
right right please I don't know Oh
open it venison everything it's a
charged creeper it blows up more unity
oh you got one
okay sometimes they give you good stuff
wait Thanos in Venice I don't have my
god gotcha okay put it down
look what there we go okay open them
though you just smash the opening
special oh no we need milk just drink
milk follow me oh thank god here drink
the tea he said there was more there was
more good ones than bad ones again okay
this time I got a good feeling about
this I got a good feeling about this one
yeah you go I go first oh you got the
knock back sick use it on the spider
okay who's ready back stick they flee be
gone thought
oh I want to know my tennis ball no
please
Oh Oh super strength
[Laughter]
okay okay jump okay save strength maybe
I'm that makes you fly even more oh oh
wait I'll stand up here in the direction
I want to see you for I keep hitting
things and stop it okay yes then they
don't crash okay I left all my inventory
Oh magic defender is hitting me
oh whoa this block spawn beak it's
beautiful we come in oh that stock box
isn't working
no I don't have it I lost it I can't
thought oh sit oh I can't find us them
either oh okay lucky block lucky buck
come on this is how you be playing now
oh my god yeah Wow nice summoned rain
under that's so awesome and epic I give
like looking like oh yeah we should play
tennis with it okay okay
nah man okay wait I serve back minecraft
tennis
oh man this thing is wild God so big our
status people what do we do so over LJ
it went from taking it too seriously -
not at all
yeah they're not Mexican Jeff a racing
horse
Jeff Lafitte the chef were you in the
ground trying to get out oh whoa Jeff is
super fat Jeff are you gonna change a
levite weight went when you when you go
past dolphins in boats they be like let
me hit Jeff while you're running oh man
I can't rest there zoom okay okay
here we go my Serbs go away okay sir
[Laughter]
Jack Manny
oh god what happened okay the court has
to stay oh no not in the whole I go bald
[Laughter]
you're on my side of the court Oh sign
oh this rules out no come come I don't
know I don't know maybe he he's like
down for a he's like I want to play yeah
come a lady come come my lady you're my
peepee bad oh my god the defense
actually keeps him in yeah 15:15 what's
you guy what you got creeper all man oh
man Oh what I hit him Oh face dancer
I'm losing quite a bit of space that was
an epic volley by beauty fiber because
I'm a big well gamer
sorry for ruining minecraft this is the
greatest thing we've ever done
okay guys next episode we're gonna make
an infinite iron farm thank you guys you
haven't tried to personally toxicity
after 50 million outros flash down just
down it's still relevant just download
it